von cruise eine wahrheit viele formen
graffiti kunst hinter dem logo von
cruise stecken die über 30 jährigen
brüder tobias und michael sen
sie haben sich den traum vom legal
sprayen erfüllt sie machen graffitis im
auftragsverhältnis jetzt sind sie quasi
auf geschäftsreise von zürich über
deutschland nach göteborg unterwegs
werden sie freigegebene wende besprechen
sponsored von einer autofirma diese
bezahlt reise unterkunft auto und garage
gestalterisch sind die künstler aber
frei erste station lörrach die brüder
sind eingeladen sich unter der
autobahnbrücke zum verewigen in der
bridge gallery deutschlands wohl größte
freiluft galerie für das legale graffiti
braunau so groß dass ein platz wo viele
gute künstler sind wir weiter sind
unsere generation her wo mir ein kurs
heftig für eine kleine und sozialberater
machen
über 100 dosen werden sie brauchen um
die wand zu besprechen
michael nennt sich pace er ist für die
schriften und abstrakten formen
zuständig tobias alias doktor drugs für
die figuren
jetzt gilt es die beiden stile zusammen
zu bringen
grundieren ist eben so schweißtreibend
wie das skizziert drecks legt die
proportionen fest ursprünglich
autodidaktisch im untergrund tätig wie
sie selber sagen nehmen die brüder
mittlerweile nur noch legale aufträge
entgegen
und davon gibt es genug in zürich
wimmelt es von ihren großflächigen
arbeiten
die witzige originalität von mont russ
ist auch in kleinformat zu haben
seit anderthalb jahren führen die brüder
ein atelier wo sie ihre typischen werke
zeigen und verkaufen
als wirkliche und graffiti an als man
wieder einiges wert das verschiedene
ganz erklärte sie später
das muss in eigenen stil einfach
bestellen megaposter jetzt dort dringend
sagt wer sich zum beispiel für die
kinder halten wie die zur stange und
vielen wie also kassierten gegenstand
figur machen jede fläche ist tracks für
seine kunst wie kann sie schaut auf der
bescheid gemischt und so ineinander
verschlungene und sie scheint beispiel
durch system lässt sich auch für mich
mega sowie die best vielleicht ist jetzt
mal bin
das blieb zurück mittlerweile gehört
auch eine professionelle buchhaltung zum
kleinen unternehmen die brüder haben
immer mehr kunden und sind jetzt auch
noch als ausbilder tätig in workshops
bringen sie schülern aus der ganzen
schweiz graffiti als legale kunst vorn
wichtig ist dass meine fragen bevor es
gab gespräche
deshalb erfolge und das ist giftig ist
in lörrach sind die meister selber am
berg auf der 15 meter wand soll eine
figur entstehen wie das handwerk der
brüder und ihre autoreise thematisiert
die herausforderung proportionen
das war sagt groß ich sehe da muss man
das level ist groß wenn man vorne
bereich
ein sprayer globetrotter für die
nachwelt der ehrenkodex unter
graffiti-künstlern jedenfalls lautet gut
gestaltete fassaden werden respektiert
und nicht übermalt